happy birthday to gab oh get out
Skeleton
Man you know who's not going to get to
work on some exciting new startup this
year George Howard scub aka the uh
alleged Scranton Strangler because he's
in prison for something he may not have
done I'm sorry the uh the Scranton who
Scranton Strangler George Howard scub
have not told you about the jury I was
on a couple years ago oh what happened I
mean if you can't talk about it
obviously cuz if you can't I mean I I I
I could I could talk about it oh see you
next Christmas sure I have a seat I
would start at the beginning but I think
I need to go farther back two times
seven Nickels at one well okay no that
doesn't add up it was one quarter
and but I was just explaining what but
why wouldn't it what did you do why
can't what is it
don't
okay are you going to kiss
me
yes expected a man did you strong
powerful huge whopping penis wow sorry
to disappoint but my huge whopping penis
is right here and I'm not afraid to use
it it so stop looking at my breasts and
start looking at my penis this is my
research into how we might produce
childproof paper that doesn't give you
paper cuts we can't and here is a print
out of your genealogy from this isy
yourfamily tree.com executive summary me
hit the highlights well it turns out you
are a distant blood relative of Michelle
Obama as in wife of Barack loves
gardening wants to wipe out fat
children you know I really do think it
would be worth it to pull over and just
take 10 minutes to
eat the thing is p I'm going to be
eating while I'm driving so I might as
well get good at it breake lights break
lights breake lights breake
lights pretty crazy about Andy and
Michelle Obama huh
yeah it's almost
unbelievable what well you know how Andy
has been really salting my onions lately
sure well when he asked me to look up
his ancestry online I remember that news
story about Michelle Obama having white
relatives and I just knew he would eat
that up so he's not related to Michelle
Obama I barely know how to turn on my
computer Nelly's pretty fearless and I
think she might be maybe even almost
sort of
fun
okay I give up what are you I'm sexy
Toby gross I love
it hey hey hey
Toby are are you
me
oh my goodness look
at look at me I look at
you it's funny
right oh still it must be great to have
something else going on outside of work
yeah turn signal it's exciting to be
painting again those are the wipers so
that it's just there you go
yeah yeah things get so busy with the
kids red light that it's nice to have
that creative Outlet red light red light
red
red call me a lay man but I wish there
was some real food here you know like um
hamburgers
or um Oreos or a pizza pie or um what's
another food that we like tacos what I
wouldn't give for a
big mess of tacos T right now I can go
get us some tacos brilliant if you want
me some money yes I can do
that for um for two tacos we probably
need about what TW uh $20 or 25 20 $30
yes um I've never eaten a Taco I'm not
entirely sure what they are as long as
they're not slimy and please God don't
let them have eyes tacos one on sale
eight for
$3 oh
great okay oh oh oh These
[Music]
tacos
m
h well that hit the spot
um very Savory uh what do you do with
the crispy holder oh here let's try this
again here don't put your finger in yeah
just hold it like that hold it to the
side right hold it to the side like lean
it to the side look at me like this
she's trying
with operation give back you pick the
Charities Dunder Mifflin supports oh boy
what's happening there's $4,000 to give
away so who has filled out their forms
Stanley American Diabetes Association um
you have diabetes Stanley I'm sorry is
the assignment to pick a selfish charity
I uh I would love to give heers
International listen to this they give a
poor person like a goat or something
It's a Great Prank I want to work with
uh Jimmy Carter and help build gnomes
Dwight what about you I will not be
participating as there is no evidence
that charity Works uh correction I give
to a foundation that teaches homeless
children nautical flag signaling changes
lives thank you Andy I'm not doing it
for you I'm doing it for the
preservation of nautical flag signaling
Dwight you will be participating no
thank you participation is mandatory
Dwight but you can choose whatever cause
you like fine I choose the global relief
Foundation great thank you which was
recently discovered to be a front for
the Taliban oh for goodness s the
Taliban in
Afghanistan the Taliban is the
worst great heroin though Dwight I
cannot have the Taliban on the roster of
operation give back well then it looks
like there won't be any operation
giveback The Nanny state is over ladies
and gentlemen you're welcome
you support the Taliban abroad so I
assume you're willing to live by their
rules
here anything else would be inconsistent
will you join me then in a pledge to
live by Taliban law in this
office absolutely I
will I feared had some sort of a plan
but she used a ridiculous font huh you
don't have a plan when you use a
ridiculous font no one thinks you have a
[Music]
plan looking for
this what
the oh this is a lovely pen and it's
mine now because I stole it give me that
didn't we sign a contract to live under
Taliban law and now there's been a theft
that means you're not serious or
someone's getting their handka off
you're insane I know so it's better that
you pick another charity oh and let your
precious operation power grab proceed
unchecked no thank you in that case
you will have to chop off my
hand this Cleaver appears to need
sharpening I suggest you spend some
quality time time together just you and
your hand tie a shoe toss a salad do any
of the twoand activities that you'll
miss the most I tell you what I need to
make three calls and then after that you
can become a person who chops off
people's hands sounds like a
plan
this is for real this
time it's getting late thought you guys
could use a little
inspiration oh a
movie what is this 127 Hours it's about
this guy who no no spoilers please my
bad my bad you're right okay good
night second best Bananas Foster I've
ever had yeah what's the first
best nights ago
twice hello Dwight it's a nelly it are
you in
there I can see the light on under your
door
hello oh look at that the light went off
just as I said the light went
off
hello
[Music]
oh
Dwight